was there anything that was more extreme  than her  absolutely um the one that really stands  out the most was uh  during an exorcism when the demon  manifested and the person's body began  to levitate  you saw somebody's body i saw a person  levitate during an exorcism how how much  was it levitation the person rose about  a foot out of the chair they were in  because i'm looking at this in disbelief  and father carmene is praying the right  of the church the prayers and he's  glancing over and looking and he looks  back at his book he looks back at the  person he looks back at his book then he  takes his hand puts it on the head of  the person and pushes them back down  into the chair without ever pausing for  one even one moment  in the prayer